.
SPEAKER:  GOOD EVENING.  WELCOME
TO THE KLUGE AUDITORIUM AT
LIBRARY OF CONGRESS.  I'M
NICHOLAS BROWN, ONE
OF THE AUTHORS OF
BIBLIODISCOTHEQUE.
WE ARE THRILLED TO HAVE YOU THIS
EVENING ON TIM GUNN ON DISCO
FASHION.  IT'S BEING BROAD
CASTED LIVE ON FACEBOOK AND
YOUTUBE.  THE LIBRARY'S DISCO
SERIES IS AN EXPLORATION OF
DISCO DANCE, MUSIC AND CULTURE
IN THE LIBRARY.  POPULAR CULTURE
IS RICHLY COLLECTED IN THE
LIBRARY'S DEPOSIT OF HIT SONGS,
SHEET MUSIC, AUDIO RECORDINGS,
MANUSCRIPT AND FEATURE FILMS.
WE ARE PRIVILEGED TO BE JOINED
THROUGHOUT THE WEEK BY LEADING
SCHOLARS, EXPERTS AND PERFORMERS
FOR DISCO DEVELOPMENT, LEGACY
AND A CULTURAL PHENOMENON.  AS
YOU PARTICIPATE IN
BIBLIODISCOTHEQUE, WE INVITE YOU
TO PARTICIPATE ONLINE
HASHTAG LC DISCO.  BE SURE TO
VISIT OUR BE DAZZLED DISCO BALL
IN FRONT OF THE THOMAS JEFFERSON
BUILDING TO GRAB A PHOTO.  THIS
PROGRAM AND ALL OF THE
BIBLIODISCOTHEQUE EVENTS ARE
MADE THROUGH SUPPORT OF THE
LIBRARY OF CONGRESS.  AS YOU
SPEND YOUR TIME HERE TONIGHT, WE
INVITE YOU TO MAKE A DONATION
VIA
LOC.GOV/DISCO.
IT'S MY PRIVILEGE TO INTRODUCE
OUR SPEAKERS THIS EVENING.
ROBERT NEWLEN WHO WILL INTRODUCE
MR. GUNN IS THE DEPUTY
LIBRARIAN OF CONGRESS.  HE HAS
SERVED AT THE LIBRARY SINCE 1975
INCLUDING CHIEF OF STAFF,
DEPUTY LAW LIBRARIAN, ASSISTANCE
KNOWLEDGE SERVICES GROUP AND
DIRECTOR OF RESEARCH SERVICE AND
CRS
LEGISLATIVE RELATIONS OFFICE.
HOLDS DEGREES FROM AMERICAN
UNIVERSITY, CATHOLIC UNIVERSITY
IN AMERICA AND BRIDGE WATER
COLLEGE.  SERVED ON THE BOARD OF
AMERICAN
LIBRARY ASSOCIATION.
TIM GUNN IS A FASHION HOST ON
EMMY PROJECT RUNWAY.  HE HAS HAD
STINTS INCLUDING LIZ CLAREBORN
OPERATED, PACIFIC AND CHAIR OF
FASHION DESIGN AT PARSONS SCHOOL
OF DESIGN.  ALSO AS A
DISTINGUISHED WRITER, GUNN HAS
SOLD BEST SELLING BOOKS AND
KATHY MCDROTAL PUT TOGETHER A
DISPLAY THIS EVENING AND YOU CAN
SEE MR. GUNN'S WORK IN THE
LOBBY.  MR. GUNN HAS WRITTEN FOR
ELLE, PEOPLE AND NEW YORK
MAGAZINE AND WRITTEN FOR NEW
YORK TIMES, MARIE CLAIRE AND
ENTERTAINMENT WEEKLY.
IMMEDIATELY FOLLOWING TONIGHT'S
INTERVIEW, MR. GUNN WILL SIGN AT
THE PAVILION WHICH IS ON TOP OF
THE AUDITORIUM RIGHT UP THE
STAIRS.  AUDIENCE, PLEASE
WELCOME ROBERT NEWLEN AND TIM
GUNN.  [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
THANK YOU.
SPEAKER:  WELL THANK YOU FOR
WOW.
THANK YOU.
SPEAKER:  WELL THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE.  OKAY.  IT'S TIME TO
GO.
SPEAKER:  WELL TIM, WELCOME TO
THE LIBRARY OF CONGRESS.  THANK
YOU FOR AGREEING TO KICK OFF OUR
WEEK OF BIBLIODISCOTHEQUE.
THIS IS QUITE AN HONOR FOR US.
SPEAKER:  ROBERT, I HAVE TO BE
HONEST, WHEN I RECEIVED THE
INVITATION.  FIRST OF ALL,
LIBRARY OF CONGRESS, I'M
ECSTATIC.  I MEAN THE WHOLE IDEA
OF BEING HERE.  AND THEN I
THOUGHT DISCO FASHION.
[LAUGHTER].  IT'S -- BUT THEN I
FELT THE LIBRARY OF CONGRESS HAS
EVERYTHING.  AND YOU DO.  SO
WHY NOT?
SPEAKER:  IT'S TRUE.  WE DO.  WE
ARE -- WE ARE GROUND ZERO FOR
INFORMATION ABOUT THE DISCO ERA,
MUSIC, FASHION.  AS YOU CAN
SEE, A LITTLE BIT OF EVERYTHING.
SPEAKER:  IT TAKES ME BACK.
[LAUGHTER].
SPEAKER:  IT'S ALSO FUN BECAUSE
YOU'RE A FELLOW WASHINGTONIAN.
SPEAKER:  I AM, GENERATIONS.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
SPEAKER:  AND A GRADUATE OF
CORCHRAN CULTURE.
SPEAKER:  YES.  FOR FIVE YEARS.
SPEAKER:  SO TELL US HOW DID YOU
MORPH FROM
CROCHRAN MAJOR.
SPEAKER:  WELL, HOW MUCH TIME DO
WE HAVE.  EVEN GETTING TO THE
CORCHRAN WAS A SERENDIPITOUS
PATH AND I HAD AN UNDER GRADUATE
DEGREE.  I DIDN'T KNOW WHAT I
WAS GOING TO BE DOING IN
LITERATURE.  I STUDIED
ARCHITECTURE.  AFTER ONE
SEMESTER OF IT, I THOUGHT THIS
IS A SURE TRIP TO AN INSANE
ASYLUM.  YOU CAN ONLY IMAGINE
PULLING INK AND A STYLUS ALONG A
STRAIGHT AGE AND 20 HOURS INTO
A DRAWING, THE WHOLE THING
BLEEDS.
I GRADUATED FROM CORCHRAN AND I
THOUGHT HOW AM I GOING TO
SUPPORT MYSELF AS A STARVING
SCULPTOR.  AND I WENT BACK IN
WASHINGTON, BUT IN A DIFFERENT
FORM OF
DEPARTURE.  AND I WAS INVITED TO
TEACH AT THE CORCHRAN.  AND IT
WAS ANOTHER TRIP TO THE ASYLUM.
FOR A WHILE I THREW UP EVERY
MORNING IN THE PARKING LOT.  I
HAD A WONDERFUL WOMAN WHO HIRED
ME.  A WONDERFUL WOMAN.  AND
DURING THE WEEK I KEPT REHEARSNG
THE TALK I NEEDED TO HAVE WITH
HER
FRIDAY AFTERNOON AFTER CLASS.
I THOUGHT I CAN'T DO THIS.  AND
SOMEONE ELSE DECIDED THEY CANNOT
RETURN TO TEACH.  AND I HAD
THIS WONDERFUL IMPASSIONED
SPEECH.  I WASN'T EATING.  I
WASN'T SLEEPING.  AND LIFE
DOESN'T MATTER ANYMORE.  SHE
LISTENED TO ME.  SHE SAYS I
TRUST THAT THIS
WILL EITHER CHANGE YOU OR KILL
YOU.  AND I THOUGHT THE LATER.
OH, NO.  I GOT TO GO BACK ON
MONDAY.  BUT CURED ME IT DID.  I
ENDED UP BEING A CAREER
ACADEMIC.  29 YEARS
IN THE CLASSROOM.  SO I WAS
INVITED TO TEACH AT PARSONS
SCHOOL OF DESIGN IN NEW YORK.
THIS WAS 1982.  AND I SAID NO,
NO, NO.
THANK YOU.  I LOVE WASHINGTON.
HAD A GREAT RELATIONSHIP.  AND
THERE WERE LOTS OF THINGS THAT
WERE HAPPENING FOR ME.  IT'S
VERY INTERESTING HOW MUCH LIFE
CAN CHANGE.  AS QUICKLY AS EIGHT
OR NINE MONTHS.  THINGS CHANGE
QUITE DRAMATICALLY.  AND I
DIDN'T KNOW WHERE I WAS GOING TO
GO OR WHAT I WAS GOING TO DO.
AND THE PHONE RANG IN THE OLDERN
DAYS WITH THE RING RING.  AND
IT WAS PARSONS SAYING WE ARE
TRYING AGAIN.  AND I SAID I WILL
COME UP AND INTERVIEW AND WE'LL
SEE.
AND TWO WEEKS LATER I WAS LIVING
IN NEW YORK.  AND THAT WAS 34
YEARS AGO.  SO ITS BEEN A LONG
RIDE.  NOW, I HAD ANOTHER ROLE
AT PARSONS OR EVENTUALLY DID.
IN 1990 I WAS APPOINTED
ASSOCIATE DEAN.  AND IN THAT
CAPACITY I WORKED WITH
DEPARTMENTS WITH CURRICULUM
DEVELOPMENTS AND FACULTY HIRING
AND FULL-TIME FACULTY HIRING AND
CHAIR HIRINGS.  BUT MOST OF IT
WAS CLEAN UP.  PEOPLE CALLED ME
MR. FIX-IT.  AND I CALLED MYSELF
A POOPER SCOOPER.  AND I WOULD
SAY THIS PLACE HAS TO STOP
POOPING SO MUCH.  AND IT WAS.
AND THAT'S HOW I LANDED IN THE
FASHION DEPARTMENT.  I NEVER --
PEOPLE SAY WHEN DID YOU FALL IN
LOVE WITH FASHION?  WELL, IT WAS
WITH A BAYNETTE IN MY BACK.  I
NEVER INTENDED TO BE PART OF THE
FASHION WORLD, IN ANY CAPACITY.
WE HAD A CRISIS OF LEADERSHIP IN
OUR FASHION PROGRAM.  WHICH AT
THE TIME, WELL, IT STILL IS
ARGUABLY THE MOST FAMOUS PROGRAM
AT PARSONS.  WE HAVE A CRISIS
OF LEADERSHIP.  I WAS SENT IN TO
CONDUCT A SEARCH FOR THE NEW
CHAIR.  AND WHEN I STARTED MY
EXCAVATION OF ISSUES, I WENT
BACK TO THE DEAN AND SAID THIS
IS NOT A QUICK FIX.  AND IT'S
NOT SOMETHING THAT AN OUTSIDER
CAN DO.  AND HE SAID, WELL I
WANT YOU TO GO IN FOR A YEAR.
SO THAT WAS THE DEAL.  I WOULD
THERE FOR A YEAR.  AND THE
LIMITS TO THE YEAR WERE THE
FOLLOWING.  I WENT IN, IN
AUGUST.  THE BUDGET SET JULY
1ST.  FACULTY CONTRACTS WERE
SET.  ROOM ASSIGNMENTS, I MEAN
EVERYTHING WAS LAID OUT FOR YOU
FOR THE COMING YEAR.  THERE IS
REALLY NOTHING YOU CAN DO EXCEPT
OBSERVE AND PROBE.  I ASKED
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF
QUESTIONS.  SO AFTER ABOUT THREE
MONTHS THERE, I WROTE A STATE
OF THE UNION OF SORTS TO THE
DEAN.
SAYING THIS PLACE IS
HEMORRHAGING.  IT'S NOT A QUICK
FIX.  IT'S MUCH WORSE THAN I
EVER DREAMED.  AND CALLING IT
FASHION DESIGN, IT'S A DRESS
MAKING SCHOOL.  IT REALLY WAS.
THERE WAS NO TALK ABOUT
CONCEPTUAL DEVELOPMENT.  THERE
WAS NO FASHION HISTORY.  OH, I
ASKED, HOW CAN THIS BE?  WE
DON'T WANT THE STUDENTS TO BE
INFLUENCED.  CAN YOU IMAGINE?
SO BURY YOURSELF IN A BASEMENT
AND PRETEND THAT FASHION HASN'T
BEEN AROUND SINCE MILLENIA.  AND
NOTHING IS DIGITAL.  IT'S THE
YEAR 2000.  SO I WILL FAST
FORWARD.  I ENDED UP BEING
APPOINTED CHAIR.  NOTHING THAT I
INTENDED TO DO.  I HAVE TO TELL
YOU A FUNNY STORY.  A DEAR
FRIEND OF MINE FOR MANY YEARS,
IT'S DIANNE VON
FOSTENBURG, SHE IS A DOLL.  SHE
WAS MY GO-TO PERSON FOR ANY KIND
OF DILEMMA.
SHE IS A REAL PROBLEM SOLVER AND
KNOWS HOW TO ASK THE RIGHT
QUESTIONS.  AND SHE KNOWS HOW
TO DIAGNOSE AND PRESCRIBE.  SO
SHE WAS MEETING WITH ME IN MY
NEW OFFICE AS CHAIR.  AND I WAS
VERY AWARE JUST IN TERMS AURA
THAT SOMETHING WAS VERY
DIFFERENT.
AND I LOOKED AT HER.  AND I SAID
WHAT'S THE MATTER?  AND SHE
LOOKED ME UP AND DOWN.  AND SHE
SAID, YOU NEED NEW CLOTHES.  SHE
SAID YOU CANNOT BE RUNNING THIS
DEPARTMENT LOOKING LIKE THIS.
AND I SAID IT'S THAT BAD?  SHE
SAID IT ALWAYS HAS BEEN.  I JUST
NEVER HAD A NEED TO TELL YOU.
[LAUGHTER].
SPEAKER:  WHAT A GREAT PIECE OF
ADVICE.  I LIKE IT.
SPEAKER:  BUT I HAVE TO TELL YOU
ANOTHER FUNNY STORY HAVING TO
DO WITH DIANNE.  I'M SORRY I'M
STRAYING.  I HAVE THIS WAY OF
TALKING.
SPEAKER:  PLEASE GO ON.  I LOVE
IT.
SPEAKER:  AS A CHAIR, THERE WERE
CERTAIN THINGS I HAD TO DO.
CURRICULUM WAS A HUGE ONE.
FACULTY WAS ANOTHER.  THERE WAS
A VERY POWERFUL FACULTY MEMBER
WHO -- AND I SAY POWERFUL
BECAUSE HE ASSERTED HIMSELF INTO
EVERYTHING.  AND DID SO VERY
INAPPROPRIATELY.  BUT IT HAD
BEEN GOING ON FOR YEARS.  AND
MANY WAYS, THE PRECEDENT HAD
BEEN SET.  AND WHO IS TO SAY TO
HIM YOU CANNOT DO THE FOLLOWING
THINGS?  AND I THOUGHT, WELL I'M
THE ONE WHO IS GOING TO SAY IT.
HIM.  I MEAN I COULD HAVE.  I
KNEW POLITICALLY IT WOULD BE
VERY DANGEROUS.  I WAS LIKE
OKAY, I NEED TO GET TO GUY TO
QUIT.  SO I WROTE HIM A VERY
MATTER-FACT LETTER LAYING OUT,
HERE ARE YOUR RESPONSIBILITIES
AND HERE THE THINGS THAT YOU
HAVE BEEN DOING AND WILL NO
LONGER BE DOING.  AND SENT IT.
WAS WAIT FOR THE REPERCUSSIONS
AND WITHIN ABOUT 10 DAYS THIS
ENORMOUS, I MEAN ENORMOUS
ENVELOPE ARRIVED.  AND IT WAS
HARD.  I MEAN, YOU COULDN'T
REALLY -- YOU COULDN'T BEND IT.
I THOUGHT, WHAT IS THIS?  WELL,
THIS INDIVIDUAL WAS AN EXTREMELY
TALENTED ARTIST.  I PULL OUT
THIS DOCUMENT THAT LOOKS LIKE A
MID EVIL MANUSCRIPT.  I MEAN, IT
WAS SPECTACULARLY STUNNING WITH
GOLD LEAF AND DRAGONS.  AND I
READ IT.  AND IT BEGAN WITH I
RECEIVED YOUR MENACNG
MISSION.
AND IT CONCLUDED WITH I QUIT.  I
WAS THRILLED.
SPEAKER:  WOW.
SPEAKER:  SO A FEW WEEKS LATER,
DIANNE WAS IN THE OFFICE.  AND I
WAS VERY LUCKY TO HAVE MY OWN
LITTLE PRIVATE RESTROOM IN MY
OFFICE.  SO I TOOK THIS THING,
THIS DOCUMENT, AND HUNG IT
BEHIND THE BATHROOM DOOR, WHICH
FACES THE
TOILET.  SO DIANNE GOES TO THE
BATHROOM AND CALLS OUT, WHAT'S A
MENACING
MISSIVE.
SPEAKER:  DO YOU STILL HAVE IT.
SPEAKER:  YEAH.
SPEAKER:  YOU'RE BRAVE.
SPEAKER:  AND PROJECT RUNWAY
CALLED.  AND I MADE -- I WILL
SAY THIS MODESTLY, BUT ALSO
RATHER -- WHAT'S THE WORD I AM
SEARCHING FOR?  I'LL JUST SAY
THIS MODESTLY.  I HAD TO MAKE
CHANGES IN THE DEPARTMENT.  AND
THEY WERE VERY CONTROVERSIAL IN
THE CASES.  AND MANY PEOPLE,
PARTICULARLY ALUMNI HATED ME.  I
WAS REALLY UNPOPULAR.  I TOOK
THIS PRECIOUS THING.  THIS
FASHION DESIGN DEPARTMENT THAT
HADN'T CHANGED IN 52 YEARS AND
TURNED IT UPSIDE DOWN.  MY
PREDECESSORS WERE KEEPERS OF
THE LINE.  AND MY PRODUCER HEARD
A LOT ABOUT ME.  YOU SHOULD GO
TALK TO HIM.  HE MADE A LOT OF
CHANGES.  ENDS WERE VERY GOOD.
AND MAYBE HE CAN HELP YOU WITH
THIS PROJECT.  SO THEY CALLED
ME.  AND I SAID -- I'LL TELL YOU
EXACTLY WHAT I SAID.  FASHION
REALITY?  THIS INDUSTRY HAS
ENOUGH TROUBLE WITHOUT THAT.  SO
THEY ASKED IF THEY CAN COME
MEET WITH ME.  AND OF COURSE, I
GOOGLED THEM.  AND I FOUND OUT
THEY WERE THE PRODUCERS OF
PROJECT GREEN LIGHT WHICH HAS A
LOT OF INTEGRITY AND PURPOSE.
AND THEY MET WITH ME.  AND I
BECAME VERY EXCITED.  THEY
WANTED TO WORK WITH REAL FASHION
DESIGNERS AND IT SOUNDED
INTERESTING.  IT SOUNDED
INTERESTING AND FUN.  BUT THEY
ASKED ME A QUESTION THAT I KNEW
WAS "THE QUESTION" SO TO SPEAK.
AND IT WAS THE FOLLOWING.  HOW
WOULD YOU RESPOND IF WE WERE TO
TELL YOU THAT WE WANT THE
DESIGNERS TO CREATE A WEDDING
DRESS IN TWO DAYS?  COMPARED TO
PROJECT RUNWAY TODAY, TWO DAYS
SOUNDS LIKE AN ETERNITY.  AND I
MEAN, I COME FROM THE
ACADEMIC WORLD.  AND WE HAVE
ARCHITECTURE WHERE YOU GET A
PROJECT ON FRIDAY NIGHT AND
CRITIQUING IT ON SUNDAY.  AND IN
FACT, WE'LL HAVE TO CREATE A
WEDDING DRESS IN TWO DAYS.  IT
CAN BE DONE.
WELL, IT CAN BE DONE.  IT'S NOT
GOING TO BE AN
OSCAR LAUREN OR A VERA WANG
GOWN, BUT IT WILL BE A SHIP
WITHOUT SLEEVES.  ACTUALLY A
COLUMN WITHOUT SLEEVES.  AND
THEN I DIDN'T HEAR FROM THEM FOR
WEEKS.  AND I THOUGHT WELL,
THAT WAS INTERESTING.  AND I WAS
THEIR CONSULTANT UP UNTIL TWO
DAYS BEFORE THE DESIGNERS
ARRIVED.  IN A WAY, I'M STILL
THEIR CONSULTANT.  BUT TWO DAYS
BEFORE THE DESIGNERS ARRIVED,
THEY ASKED ME IF I WOULD GO INTO
THE WORK ROOM AND PUMBLE THE
DESIGNERS WITH QUESTIONS ABOUT
WHAT THEY ARE DOING.  AND I
THOUGHT, THAT'S HOW I SPENT MOST
OF MY LIFE.  SURE.  I TOLD YOU
BACK STAGE, I NEVER DREAMED OF
BEING THE CUT OF THE SHOW.  I
THOUGHT AS LONG AS THEY HAVE THE
DESIGNERS RESPONDING TO ME, NO
ONE NEEDS TO HEAR MY VOICE.  NO
ONE NEEDS TO SEE ME.  AND FOR
THAT REASON, I DIDN'T GO TO THE
PREMIERE PARTY.  WELL, IF I'M IN
THE SHOW.  WHAT WILL I LOOK
LIKE AND SOUND LIKE?  AND IF I'M
NOT IN THE SHOW, I WILL BE KIND
OF HUMILIATED.  SO I WATCHED
THE PREMIERE ON TELEVISION.  I
WATCHED IT, THE SAME WAY THAT I
USED TO WATCH "THE WIZARD OF OZ"
WHERE I WAS IN BED PEEKING OUT
FROM BEHIND MY SHEETS.  I HADN'T
SEEN ANYTHING IN ADVANCE.  I
THOUGHT, I DON'T KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE GOING TO SHOW.  MAYBE
IT'S SEXUAL
ESCAPADES IN THE APARTMENT.  I
HAVE NO IDEA.  AND THE FIRST
FIVE AS SOON AS OF THE SHOW WE
WERE ON BRAVO AND DURING THE
TAPING OF THE FIRST SEASON,
THERE WAS A WOMAN STANDING NEXT
TO ME IN THE DARKNESS OF THE
BACK OF THE PARSONS AUDITORIUM
WHERE WE FILMED THE RUNWAY SHOW
WITH THE DESIGNERS AND THE
JUDGE'S DELIBERATION.  AND WE
WERE WATCHING THE JUDGE'S
DELIBERATION.  AND THIS PERSON,
UNKNOWN TO ME, TURNED TO ME AND
ASKED, WHO IS GOING TO WANT TO
WATCH THIS?  AND THE PERSON WAS
THE PRESIDENT OF BRAVO.
[LAUGHTER].  SO WHO KNEW?  I
MEAN, AND ALSO AT AGE 50, I HAD
AN ENTIRELY NEW THRESHOLD TO MY
LIFE.  I MEAN, IT WAS
PHENOMENAL.  AND I HAD A VERY
HAPPY, VERY REWARDING
SPIRITUALLY CAREER.
SPEAKER:  SO OVER THE COURSE OF
PROJECT RUNWAY, HOW HAVE YOU
CHANGED AS ONE WHO CRITIQUES
DESIGN AS A TEACHER, AS A
MENTOR?
SPEAKER:  THAT'S AN INTERESTING
QUESTION.  WELL, ACTUALLY,
BECOMING A MENTOR WAS VERY
CHALLENGING.  IN WAYS THAT I
DIDN'T THINK THAT IT WOULD.
BECAUSE I BECAME AWARE VERY
QUICKLY THAT I HAD TO TAKE OFF
MY TEACHER'S HAT AND ACTUALLY IT
HAPPENED, EPISODE 1.  SEASON 1
EPISODE 1.  I WAS IN THE SEWING
ROOM THREADING A BOBBIN.
BECAUSE ONE OF THE DESIGNERS WAS
HAVING DIFFICULTY DOING IT.
JANE LIPSIT ONE OF THE EXECUTIVE
PRODUCERS IS KNOCKING BECAUSE
SHE HAS A FEED, THERE IS A FEED
IN EVERY ROOM.  KNOCKING ON THE
SEWING ROOM DOOR.  SAYING TIM,
CAN I SPEAK TO YOU IN THE
HALLWAY?  WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
I'M THREADING A BOBBIN.  SHE
SAID YOU CAN'T DO THAT.  WHY
NOT?  BECAUSE IT'S A FAIRNESS
ISSUE.  IF YOU THREAD THE BOBBIN
FOR THAT DESIGNER, YOU HAVE TO
THREAD THE BOBBIN FOR ALL OF THE
DESIGNERS.  AND I SAID I'M OUT
OF THE SEWING ROOM AND I'M NOT
GOING TO BECOME THE BOBBING
THREADING HAND MAIDEN.  AND I
ALSO LEARNED DURING THE
CRITIQUES -- AND I HAVE BEEN
LIKE THIS.  THE MENTOR YOU SEE
IN THE WORK ROOM IS VERY MUCH
THE WAY THAT I EVOLVED AS A
TEACHER.  BECAUSE IN THE EARLY
DAYS OF TEACHING, I THINK IT'S
SOMEWHAT NATURAL FOR AT LEAST
NOVICES TO WANT TO MAKE SURE
STUDENTS INTO LITTLE MINI ME'S.
I WANT YOU TO HAVE THE SAME --
WORK HABITS AND ALL OF THE
MYRIAD THINGS THAT GO WITH THAT,
PUCTUALITY AND BREAK TIME AND
THE THING THAT I EVOLVED TO WAS,
WHAT ARE YOU TRYING TO DO?  AND
HOW WELL ARE YOU SUCCEEDING AT
THIS?  WHAT ISSUES ARE YOU
HAVING?  I DEVELOPED A VERY
SOCRATIC APPROACH TO TEACHING.
HUMBLING PEOPLE WITH QUESTIONS.
AND I WILL SAY THIS FOR ANY
TEACHERS OR WOULD-BE TEACHERS IN
THIS ROOM.  AND ANOTHER THING
THAT I RID MYSELF UP.  THE
DEBILITATING THROWING UP PART OF
IT, FEELING THAT I WAS
RESPONSIBLE FOR EVERY KERNEL OF
INFORMATION.  THAT I HAD TO BE
THIS VUNDER KENT ANSWER MAN. AND
IT WAS JUST
DEBILITATING.  SO WHAT I
EVOLVED TO, IF SOMEONE WERE TO
ASK A QUESTION, IF A STUDENT
WERE TO ASK A QUESTION.
I WOULD SAY, INTERESTING
QUESTION.  FOR THE NEXT CLASS, I
WANT ALL OF YOU TO RESEARCH
THIS QUESTION.  AND COME IN WITH
AN ANSWER THAT YOU DON'T THINK
ANYONE ELSE WOULD HAVE FOUND.
SO THEY HAD TO DIG DEEP.  AND
THEN WE WOULD SHARE IT ALL.  AND
IT WAS FANTASTIC.  BECAUSE THE
CONVERSATION THAT WOULD EVOLVE
FROM THAT ONE QUESTION WOULD BE
A CATALYST FOR A MILLION OTHER
THINGS AND WOULD TAKE US INTO A
DIRECTION OF A MILLION OTHER
THINGS, AND WAS A HUGE
ENHANCEMENT FOR THE COURSE
SYLLABUS AND FOR ME TO MOVE INTO
THE MENTOR POSITION ON RUNWAY.
I WON'T SAY IT WAS EASY.  I WAS
A NERVOUS WRECK.  I WAS
ESPECIALLY A NERVOUS WRECK IF
HEIDI WAS EVER AROUND.  MY PALMS
WOULD SWEAT.  SHE IS VERY -- I
MEAN SHE IS A LOVELY FANTASTIC
PERSON WHO I LOVE DEARLY.  BUT
SHE IS HEIDI KLUM.
SPEAKER:  YEAH.  THAT CAN BE
VERY INTIMIDATNG I'M SURE.
SPEAKER:  BUT IT WAS A JOURNEY.
SPEAKER:  RIGHT.
SPEAKER:  AND ONE THAT I REALLY
LOVED.
SPEAKER:  SO WHAT IS IT LIKE
ACTUALLY DOING PROJECT RUNWAY?
HOW LONG DOES IT TAKE YOU TO DO
IT?
SPEAKER:  WELL WE DO THE BULK OF
IT WHICH CONSISTS OF 12
CHALLENGES IN 31 DAYS.  WE HAVE
NO BREAKS.  SOMETIMES 18 HOUR,
SOMETIMES 20 HOUR DAYS.  I LOVE
PROJECT RUNWAY JUNIOR.  WE HAVE
TO ABIDE BY THE CHILD LABOR
LAWS.  IT'S
LIKE A VACATION.
IT'S SO WONDERFUL.  THE DAY ENDS
AND EVERYONE IS OFF THE CLOCK.
FOR RUNWAY, IF IT'S DECIDED THAT
THE WORK ROOM IS GOING TO NOT
CLOSE AT 12:00 AND WE STAY OPEN
UNTIL 2:00, WE SHARE IT WITH THE
AUDIENCE.  WE NEVER
MISREPRESENT THINGS.  AND THEN
I'M THERE UNTIL 2:00.  IT'S
FINE.  IT'S A HIGH CLASS
PROBLEM.  THE LONG DAYS.  AND I
WILL SAY, IT GETS TO ALL OF US.
I MEAN, IT'S A CUMULATIVE
EXHAUSTION.
MENTALLY, PHYSICALLY,
CREATIVELY.  IT GETS TO US.  BUT
I WOULDN'T NOT DO IT.  AND IT'S
FOR BUDGET REASONS THAT WE DO
IT IN SUCH A SHORT PERIOD OF
TIME.
AND THERE IS A HIATUS.  AND I DO
THE HOME VISIT WHICH IS 10 DAYS
INCLUDING TRAVEL.  AND THEN
THERE IS ANOTHER VERY SMALL
HIATUS AND THEN WE HAVE FASHION
WEEK.  WHICH TAKES US FIVE DAYS
BEGINNING TO END.
SPEAKER:  WONDERFUL.  WELL, ONE
OF THE REASONS THAT WE'RE HERE
IS TO CELEBRATE DISCO.  THE
WHOLE DISCO ERA AND WE'RE BOTH
PRODUCTS OF THAT ERA.
SPEAKER:  REGRETTABLY.
SPEAKER:  WHAT DO YOU THINK
DEFINES DISCO IN TERMS OF
FASHION?
SPEAKER:  WELL, I WANT TO GIVE
IT A BIT OF A CONTEXT.  WE'RE
COMING OUT OF THE 1960S, WHICH
WAS IN MY VIEW, THE MOST
REVOLUTIONARY DECADE IN FASHION
EVER.  I MEAN, WE USHERED IN
WITH MAD MEN PRIMNUS AND
BUTTONED UPNESS FOR MEN.  AND
WE USHER IT OUT WITH HIPPIES.
AND WE HAVE THE CLEAR VINYL
DRESS COURTESY OF YSL.  WE HAVE
THE PAPER DRESS.  THAT'S WHY
TODAY, ESPECIALLY THOSE, OH, GOD
THOSE HORRIBLE KARDASHIANS
RUNNING AROUND.  [LAUGHTER].
I'LL BE HONEST WITH YOU.  THE
ONLY
THING THAT MAKES ME RISE MORE
IS WHAT'S GOING ON IN THE WHITE
HOUSE.  [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
BUT TRULY, AFTER THE '60S,
FASHION WISE, I'M PRETTY
UNSHOCKABLE.  SO WE HAVE THIS
TERM OIL.  WE ENTER INTO THE
'70S AND THERE ARE CERTAIN
ASPECTS OF IT BROAD MEN.  WE HAD
A PEACOCK MOMENT OF MEN IN THE
'60S WITH EXTRAVAGANT DRESS AND
MELTED BEAUTIFULLY INTO THE
WHOLE DISCO MOVEMENT.  WE HAD A
KIND OF BODY AWARENESS WITH
WOMEN.  WHERE VERY LITTLE WAS
LEFT TO THE IMAGINATION.  AND
THAT CERTAINLY SEGUED VERY
BEAUTIFULLY INTO DISCO. IT WAS A
TIME OF FLAMBOYANCE.  IT WAS A
TIME OF DIFFERENTIATION AND
EVERYONE WANTED TO STAND OUT.  I
AM ALWAYS TALKING ABOUT THE
CLOTHES, THE CLOTHES WE WEAR
SEND A MESSAGE ABOUT HOW THE
WORLD PERCEIVES US.  YOU WANTED
TO BE DISTINCTIVE AND DIFFERENT
ON THAT DISCO DANCE FLOOR.  IT
WAS REALLY A GIANT RUNWAY OF
SORTS.  AND IT WAS SEXUALLY
CHARGED.  SOCIOLOGICALLY
CHARGED.  IDENTITY CHARGED.
THERE WERE GENDER-BENDING
ASPECTS TO DISCO CULTURE.  AND
WE SEE THE RISE OF CERTAIN
DESIGNERS IN THAT PERIOD WHO
ALSO WERE
INEXTRICABLE FROM THE MOVEMENT.
HOLTSTON BEING THE MOST
PROMINENT, WORKING WITH JERSEY
WHO HAD STRETCHED.  HOW CRAZY
WOULD IT BE WEARING HOLTSTON ON
THE DANCE FLOOR.
DIANNE VON
FURSTENBURG ANOTHER, NORMA
CANOLLI, ICONIC IN THE '70S AND
ENTRENCHED IN DISCO CULTURE.  IT
WAS A PHENOMENAL TIME.  AND
IT'S DEBATABLE, AND ARGUABLE.
BUT MANY PEOPLE SAY
THAT DISCO CULTURE CAME OUT OF A
GAY SUBCULTURE.  AND I BELIEVE
THAT.  IN MANY WAYS IT DID.  AND
COINCIDENTALLY, I AM SURE MANY
OF YOU ARE ENTIRELY TOO YOUNG TO
HAVE ANY AWARENESS OF THIS.  IN
SOME WAYS I THINK YOU SHOULD.
IN 1973 HOMO SEXUALITY WAS
REMOVED FROM THE LIST OF
PSYCHIATRIC DISORDERS BY THE
AMERICAN MEDICAL ASSOCIATION.
SO SUDDENLY YOU DIDN'T HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT BEING OUT.  BECAUSE
PRIOR TO THAT, TO YOU CAN BE
LOCKED UP.  I
MEAN, LEGALLY.  SO THIS
SUBCULTURE COULD EMERGE AND
BECOME -- I DON'T WANT TO SAY
MAIN STREAM.  BUT ACTUALLY
EMBRACED BY THE MAIN STREAM.  I
MEAN, THE WONDERFUL THING ABOUT
DISCO CULTURE, IT WAS ALL
INCLUSIVE.  IT DIDN'T CARE WHERE
YOU CAME FROM, WHO YOU WERE,
WHAT YOUR IDENTITY WAS, WHAT
RACE YOU WERE.  IT EMBRACED
EVERYBODY.  AND IT WAS --
ACTUALLY I DID A LITTLE BIT OF
RESEARCH IN IF ANTICIPATION OF
OUR INTERVIEW.  I THOUGHT, WHAT
DO I REALLY KNOW ABOUT THIS?  I
DIDN'T REALIZE THAT BY 1978 IN
THIS COUNTRY ALONE, THERE WERE
10,000 DISCO TECHS.
SPEAKER:  OH, I HAD NO IDEA.
SPEAKER:  THAT'S A STAGGERING
NUMBER.
SPEAKER:  IT IS.
SPEAKER:  AND OF COURSE THE
GRAND PUBA OF THEM ALL WAS
STUDIO 54.
SPEAKER:  YEAH.  AMAZING.  SO
FROM THIS PERIOD, DO YOU HAVE
ANY KIND OF YOUR OWN FASHION
RECOLLECTION?  THINGS THAT YOU
WERE WEARING?  IS THERE ANYTHING
IN YOUR CLOSET THAT YOU WANT TO
TELL US ABOUT?  [LAUGHTER].
SPEAKER:  YOU KNOW, I HAVE THIS
THEORY CALLED THE MONKEY HOUSE
AT THE ZOO.  AND IT IS THE
FOLLOWING.  WHEN YOU FIRST WALK
INTO THE MONKEY HOUSE, YOU
SHRIEK THIS PLACE STINKS.  AND
AFTER 20 MINUTES YOU SAY, THIS
DOESN'T SMELL SO BAD.  AND AFTER
30 MINUTES, YOU THINK, WHAT
SMELL?  BUT ANYONE NEW WALKING
IN SAYS THIS PLACE STINKS.  THAT
WAS MY '70S FASHION.  I PUT ON
THE POLYESTER PANTS AND THE
FLORAL SHIRT AND I THOUGHT THIS
IS UNACCEPTABLE AND ATROCIOUS.
AND AFTER 20 MINUTES, I THOUGHT
YOU KNOW, I LOOK KIND OF HIP.
AND AFTER 30 MINUTES, I THOUGHT,
OKAY, I CAN LEAVE MY APARTMENT
NOW.  BUT LOOKING BACK AT IT,
WHAT WERE WE THINKING?
SPEAKER:  RIGHT.  WELL, TIM, I
WENT INTO MY CLOSET.
SPEAKER:  WHAT DID YOU FIND?
SPEAKER:  [LAUGHTER].
SPEAKER:  ROBERT YOU STILL HAVE
THEM?  ARE YOU WAITING FOR THE
RETURN?
SPEAKER:  I WISH I CAN GET MY
FOOT IN THEM.  1977, I BOUGHT
THESE IN PARIS.  I WAS STUDYING
IN FRANCE.  YES, I THOUGHT I WAS
THE COOLEST THING THAT EVER HIT
THE EARTH.
SPEAKER:  WELL, YOU WERE.
SPEAKER:  SO WHY DO I STILL HAVE
THESE?
SPEAKER:  WHY DO YOU?
SPEAKER:  I HAVE NO IDEA.
[CHEERS AND
APPLAUSE].
SPEAKER:  THAT IS HILARIOUS.
ALL I CAN SAY IS THANK GOD FOR
TINY NEW YORK APARTMENTS.
BECAUSE UNLESS I RESIGN MYSELF
TO BEING A HOARDER, I GET
RID OF THINGS.  THAT'S
EXTRAORDINARY.
SPEAKER:  ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
YOU WERE TELLING ME BACK STAGE,
BACK IN YOUR CAREER THAT
SURPRISED ME WAS THAT YOU HAVE
TO HAVE YOUR OWN WARDROBE.
SPEAKER:  OH, I DO.  I SUPPLY
EVERYTHING.
SPEAKER:  I THOUGHT YOU WERE
JUST SITTING BACK, AND PEOPLE
WERE HOLDING UP OUTFITS.
SPEAKER:  NO.  BUT YOU JUST
TRIGGERED A STORY THOUGH THAT
HAS LEFT MY MIND.  YEAR ONE OF
PROJECT RUNWAY, IT'S 2004,
BANANA REPUBLIC WAS ONE OF THE
SPONSORS OF THE SHOW.  IN FACT,
WE HAD THE BANANA REPUBLIC
CHALLENGE FIRST TWO YEARS.  AND
THEY WERE GOING TO WARDROBE ME.
OUTFIT ME.  AND COINCIDENTALLY,
I WAS A BIG BANANA REPUBLIC FAN.
AND DIANNE VON
FURSTENBURG SAID ARE YOU GOING
TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT THIS.  I
WENT TO SAKS AND FOUND A BLAZER
THAT I TRULY LOVED.  IT WAS
EXPENSIVE.  AND THEN I WALKED
ACROSS THE STREET TO THE BANANA
REPUBLIC OF FLAGSHIP ACROSS THE
STREET BY ROCKEFELLER CENTER.  I
REMEMBER BANANA REPUBLIC BEING
KHAKIS, AND GOING INTO THE
AMAZON.  AND I FOUND THE
IDENTICAL JACKET MORE OR LESS
FOR 25 -- FOR 75 PERCENT LESS.
IT WAS A MERE 25 PERCENT OF THE
PRICE.  I BOUGHT IT.  AND TOOK
THE JACKET BACK TO SAKS.  AND I
DISCOVERED THE WORLD OF BANANA
REPUBLIC.  AND I HAD A LOT OF
THE CLOTHES.  AND I WAS
THRILLED.  I WAS GOING TO GET
NEW STUFF AND THEY WERE
ANTICIPATING WHEN THE STUFF
WOULD BE AIRED, IT WOULD BE NEW
FALL CLOTHES.  AT ANY RATE,
NOTHING CAME.  NOTHING CAME.
NOTHING CAME.  SO THEN, SOME
CALLS WERE MADE, AND CLOTHES DID
ARRIVE TAPED TO A BICYCLE
MESSENGER'S BIKE, A BAG OF
BANANA REPUBLIC CLOTHES.  I WAS
WEARING BANANA REPUBLIC CLOTHES
EVERY DAY.  BUT IT WAS MY BANANA
REPUBLIC CLOTHES.  NOT THEIRS.
SO I GOT A STEAMER.  AND WORKED
ITSELF OUT.  AND AT THE END OF
THE SEASON, THEY WANTED
EVERYTHING BACK INCLUDING THE
SOCKS.  SO I DRY CLEANED
EVERYTHING.  AND I HAD MADE
CERTAIN ALL OF THE SOCKS WERE
LAUNDERED AND I WAS THEN LATER
ASKED, THIS IS GETTING REALLY
TEDIOUS, I'M SORRY EVERYONE.  I
WAS ASKED, LAUREN DAVID PENEN
WROTE FOR WOMEN'S DAILY AND HAD
A REGULAR FEATURE OF GIVING
SOMEONE 100 DOLLARS AND WHAT
WOULD YOU BUY?  OH, THERE IS A
RAIN COAT ON SALE AT BANANA
REPUBLIC AND IT'S 100 DOLLARS
AND I WILL PAY THE TAX.  AND
TALKING ABOUT TAKING THE
CLOTHES BACK.  ALL HELL BROKE
LOOSE.
DON'T TAKE THEM BACK IF YOU
DON'T WANT TO TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THEM.  I WAS
FLABBERGASTED.  SEASON TWO,
BANANA REPUBLIC IS BACK.  AND I
AM STILL WEARING BANANA
REPUBLIC.  I'M WEARING THEIR
CLOTHES BUT I'M TURNED OFF BY
THE PUBLIC RELATIONS.  AND THE
PEOPLE WITH THE SPONSORS SAY TO
ME, WE NEED AN INVENTORY OF
EVERYTHING YOU WORE THIS SEASON.
WHY?  WE NEED TO CREDIT BANANA
REPUBLIC WITH IT.  I SAID, WELL
I'M WEARING BANANA REPUBLIC BUT
IT'S ALL MINE.  THE CLOTHES
NEVER CAME.  AND THEY DIDN'T.
ONCE AGAIN, ALL HELL BROKE
LOOSE.  I MEAN, I LOVE BEING I A
TRUTH TELLER.  BUT IT DOES
CAUSE SOME PROBLEMS.  I AM
RESPONSIBLE FOR MY WARDROBE.
AND I TAKE THAT ROLE VERY
SERIOUSLY.  AND IT MEANS THAT I
NEED TO GET NEW THINGS EVERY
YEAR.  AND I TAKE A LOT OF
THINGS TO GOOD WILL AND HOUSING
WORKS BECAUSE I HAVE SMALL NEW
YORK CLOSETS AND IF ANYONE IS
WONDERING, NO, YOU CAN'T WRITE
THEM OFF IN YOUR TAXES.  ONCE
ANYTHING LEAVES THE STUDIO, OF
COURSE I'M ON THE SUBWAY EVERY
DAY, SO IT LEAVES THE STUDIO.  I
DON'T HAVE A DRESSING ROOM.  I
DON'T HAVE A PLACE TO CHANGE.
SO IT'S MINE.
BUT THAT ALSO MEANS I CAN DO
WHAT I WANT WITH IT.
SPEAKER:  THAT'S GREAT.  WELL,
TIM WE'RE GOING TO TURN IN A
MOMENT JUST TO SOME QUESTIONS
FROM THE AUDIENCE.
SPEAKER:  OH, THRILLING.
SPEAKER:  IT WILL BE FUN.  BUT I
HAVE TWO MORE QUESTIONS THAT
EVERYBODY REALLY WANTS TO KNOW.
AND I MUST GIVE THEM TO YOU NOW.
SPEAKER:  UH-OH.
SPEAKER:  THE FIRST IS, DO YOU
HAVE A TATTOO?
SPEAKER:  YOU KNOW, IT'S
SOMETHING I FANTASIZE ABOUT.
AND AT THE MOMENT, NO.  BECAUSE
I HAVE A SERIOUS ADVERSION TO
PAIN.  BUT IF I WAS TO EVER GET
A TATTOO, AND HONEST TRUTH, I
HAVE SAID THIS MANY TIMES, IT
WOULD BE MY LIBRARY OF CONGRESS
CATALOG NUMBER.  ONE OF THEM.
SPEAKER:  BRAVO.  [CHEERS AND
APPLAUSE].  ALSO, IN A WAY, WHEN
YOU THINK ABOUT TATTOOS, AND I
MEAN THIS WITH ALL RESPECT,
DON'T YOU THINK IT'S AN
ANTEDOTE.  THIS IS GREAT.
SPEAKER:  IT'S WONDERFUL.  WE'RE
GOING TO GO PLACES WITH THAT.
I'M NOT SURE HOW YET.  BUT WE'RE
GOING TO GO THERE.  ACTUALLY
JUST TWO MORE THINGS.  COULD YOU
GIVE US ANY DISH ON YOUR
CO-STARS?
SPEAKER:  COULD I?
LET ME PUT IT THIS WAY.  HEIDI
IS A DOLL.
THERE ISN'T A DEVIOUS BONE IN
HER BODY.  AND ALL YOU NEED TO
KNOW IS THAT CREW MEMBERS ADORE
HER.  THEY DO NOT SEPARATE.  AND
THEN THERE ARE THE OTHER TWO.
I HAVE TO INTERACT WITH THEM
SINCE SEASON 12.  I HAVE HAD TO
SIT WITH THEM
FOR THE RUNWAY SHOW.
I'M TELLING YOU, COMING DOWN THE
RUNWAY.  WE'RE SUPPOSED TO BE
LOOKING AT IT.  AND FOR ME, YOU
CAN SAY, YOU ALREADY KNOW WHAT
THE WORK IS.  NO, I HAVEN'T SEEN
IT WALK.  I HAVEN'T SEEN IT ON
MODELS.  I HAVEN'T SEEN HOW THE
PROPORTIONS WORK WITH THE
PROPORTIONS OF THE BODY.  I
HAVEN'T SEEN IT WALK.  AND THE
JUDGES HAVEN'T SEEN IT AT ALL.
AT LEAST I SAW IT IN THE WORK
ROOM.  I WILL BE SITTING THERE
STUDYING THE SHOW AND NINA WILL
LEAN OVER AND ASK, SO HOW IS
YOUR
SUMMER?  LOOK AT THE SHOW.
I USED TO SAY, BEFORE I
INTERACTED WITH THEM, THAT I
WOULD SAY HELLO TO THE JUDGES
WHEN THEY ARRIVED.  BUT I
FREQUENTLY DIDN'T SAY GOOD BYE
BECAUSE I WAS MAD.  SO I STILL
DON'T SAY GOOD BYE.  BUT I DO
SAY HELLO.
SPEAKER:  THAT'S GOOD.  WELL MY
LAST QUESTION IS REALLY ON THE
SERIOUS SIDE.  MANY OF US ARE
FAMILIAR WITH YOUR VERY MOVING
VIDEO ON THE IT GETS BETTER
PROJECT.
SPEAKER:  THANK YOU.
SPEAKER:  BEAUTIFUL.
[APPLAUSE].  AND YOU HAVE DONE
SO MUCH WORK CHANTING PREVENTION
OF TEEN SUICIDE.  AND HOW DO
YOU MANAGE ALL OF THE CHARITABLE
WORK THAT YOU'RE DOING WITH
THIS VERY DEMANDING PROFESSION?
SPEAKER:  WELL, I CONSIDER IT A
RESPONSIBILITY.  YOU JUST HAVE
TO MAKE TIME FOR IT.  IT'S VERY,
VERY IMPORTANT TO GIVE BACK.
AND HAVING SPENT MOST OF MY
LIFE, WELL ALL OF MY LIFE REALLY
WITH YOUNG PEOPLE, WITH
ESPECIALLY STUDENTS AND
KNOWING HOW PAINFUL NAVIGATING
THE WORLD CAN BE.  AND GROWING
UP CAN BE.
I'M A SQUISH.  I MEAN, I HAVE A
SOFT SPOT FOR THAT KIND OF PAIN
AND ANGUISH.  I THOUGHT I WOULD
NEVER BE DELIVERED FROM IT.  AND
TO BE ABLE TO SAY TO PEOPLE,
INDIVIDUALS, IT REALLY DOES GET
BETTER.  BUT I HAVE TO SAY THIS
TOO TO EVERYONE.  LIFE IS A
COLLABORATION.  WE DO NOT DO
THINGS ALONE.  AND WE CERTAINLY
DON'T GET BETTER ALONE.  AND I
HAD -- I WAS LUCKY TO HAVE -- I
DIDN'T THINK I WAS LUCKY AT THE
TIME.  I THOUGHT IT WAS
ABSOLUTELY HORRIBLE.  I WAS
LUCKY TO HAVE AN INTERVENTION BY
AN INCREDIBLE DOCTOR WHO
WOULDN'T PUT UP WITH MY
NONSENSE.  HE SAVED ME.  AND
STOOD BY ME.  I'M FOREVER
GRATEFUL.
SPEAKER:  THANK GOD.  SO THANK
YOU.  I THINK WE WOULD LIKE TO
TURN TO SOME QUESTIONS FROM THE
AUDIENCE.
SPEAKER:  I LOVE IT.
SPEAKER:  OUR STAFF HAS
MICROPHONES AND IT'S KIND OF
BRIGHT UP HERE.  ANY QUESTIONS,
COME UP.  HERE WE GO.  READY FOR
OUR CLOSE UPS.  WE HAVE A
QUESTION.
SPEAKER:  I JUST WANT TO SAY,
YOU'RE A FABULOUS LOOKING
AUDIENCE.  [APPLAUSE].  I AM SO
GLAD THE LIGHTS WENT UP.  WHERE
IS OUR QUESTION?
AUDIENCE MEMBER:  HI.  YOU HAVE
I THINK THE BEST WASHINGTON,
D.C. STORY I HAVE EVER HEARD.  I
WAS WONDERING IF YOU CAN TELL
US AGAIN ABOUT VIVIAN VINCE.
SPEAKER:  YES, MY FATHER WAS AN
FBI AGENT FOR 26 YEARS.  AND HE
WAS IN A FIELD OFFICE IN NEWARK,
NEW JERSEY OF ALL PLACES FOR
THREE OF THOSE YEARS AND THEN
WAS MOVED TO HEADQUARTERS.  AND
MY FATHER WAS A VERY TALENTED
WRITER AND ENDED UP BEING
HOOVER'S GHOST WRITER AND SPEECH
WRITER AND TOOK CARE OF ALL OF
THE CORRESPONDENTS AND MY SISTER
AND I WOULD FIST THE FBI
HEADQUARTERS ONCE A YEAR AND
TAKE THE FBI TOUR.  IT'S A REAL
THRILL.  AND IT PROBABLY STILL
IS.  AND REMEMBER, THIS IS THE
OLD ER DAYS OF HUBERT.  IT WAS
NOT A PRESIDENTIAL APPOINTMENT.
IN FACT, I HAVE A WHOLE
CONSPIRACY THEORY ABOUT HIS
DEATH.  SO THIS ONE PARTICULAR
DAY MY FATHER SAID TO MY SISTER
AND ME, VIVIAN VANCE IS VISITING
MR. HOOVER.  AND I WAS A HUGE
"I LOVE LUCY" FAN AND I AM A
HUGE "I LOVE LUCY" FAN AND WAS
LIKE, WOULD YOU LIKE TO MEET
HER?  OF COURSE.  WHO WOULDN'T.
IT WAS THRILLING.  IT WAS
BEFORE SELFIES AND LITTLE
PORTABLE PHONES AND THINGS OF
THAT SORT.
SO THERE WAS NO DOCUMENTATION.
WE MET VIVIAN VANCE.  IT WAS
GREAT.  YEARS LATER, MY  FATHER
HAS PASSED.  ALL OF THE STUFF
COMES OUT ABOUT HOOVER BEING A
CROSS DRESSER.  AND IT WAS
THANKSGIVING DINNER AND I TURN
TO MY SISTER.  AND I SAID
REMEMBER THE VISIT TO MR.
MR. HOOVER'S OFFICE WHERE WE MET
VIVIAN VANCE.  AND I SAID, DO
YOU THINK IT WAS ODD THAT MR.
HOOVER WASN'T IN THE OFFICE?
PUT A CURLY FRIGHT WIG ON MR.
HOOVER, IT'S MR. MERTZ.
WOW.  SO I WROTE ABOUT THIS.  I
THINK IT WAS IN RULES.  AND THE
CHECKER HAD TO GO THROUGH
EVERYTHING.  AND WHEN I GOT TO
THE STORY.  THEY CONTACTED
VIVIAN VANCE'S TWO BIOGRAPHERS
AND THEY KNEW NOTHING ABOUT A
VISIT TO THE FBI.  AND THEN THEY
CHECKED THE VISITOR LOGS OF THE
FBI.
SPEAKER:  OH, MY GOSH.  THAT IS
SOME WASHINGTON
FOOTNOTE.  WOW.
SPEAKER:  BUT IF VIVIAN VANCE
WERE STILL ALIVE AND WERE TO
VISIT THE WHITE HOUSE, THERE
WOULD STILL BE NO RECORD.
[APPLAUSE].
SPEAKER:  OH, WE HAVE A QUESTION
RIGHT HERE.
SPEAKER:  HI.
AUDIENCE MEMBER:  HI.  I'M
JENNIFER.  OF ALL THE THINGS
THAT YOU SEE CELEBRITIES THAT
ARE JUST PEOPLE TODAY, THAT WE
WEAR, THAT IS YOUR LEAST
FAVORITE TREND?
SPEAKER:  WHAT IS MY LEAST
FAVORITE?
AUDIENCE MEMBER:  TREND.  TREND
TODAY.
SPEAKER:  OH, MY GOD.  I'M GOING
TO OFFEND SOME PEOPLE.  CAN I
ASK THIS QUESTION?  WHEN DID THE
LEGGING BECOME A PANT?  [CHEERS
AND APPLAUSE].  WHEN DID IT
HAPPEN?  YOU KNOW IT'S A CLASSIC
MONKEY HOUSE ITEM.  YOU KNOW IT
IS.  I CAN'T GO OUT WEARING
THESE.  AND 30 MINUTES LATER,
I LOOK HOT.  I DON'T UNDERSTAND
IT.  IT'S A FORM OF UNDER
GARMENT.  WEAR IT UNDER A TUNIC
OR A PAIR OF SHORTS OR A DRESS.
IT'S NOT A PANT.
SPEAKER:  YOU HEARD IT HERE
FIRST WASHINGTON, D.C.
SPEAKER:  REALLY.
SPEAKER:  OKAY WE HAVE ONE RIGHT
UP HERE.
AUDIENCE MEMBER:  HI.  SO MANY
OF THE CHALLENGES ON PROJECT
RUNWAY SEEM TO BE RUN BY THE
SPONSORS.
SPEAKER:  OH, THEY ARE.
AUDIENCE MEMBER:  HAVE YOU EVER
GOTTEN ONE THAT YOU WERE JUST
DISGUSTED BY?
SPEAKER:  YES, BUT FORTUNATELY
WE -- THE SPONSOR GOES AWAY.
BECAUSE HEIDI AND I SAY WE WON'T
DO IT.  WE WON'T DO IT.  IF YOU
CAN BELIEVE IT, THE ONES THAT
YOU DO SEE ARE MODIFIED AND
MITIGATED IN SUCH A WAY THAT
THEY ACTUALLY AT LEAST, FROM MY
POINT OF VIEW, WORK.  ALTHOUGH
THERE IS
SOME EXCEPTIONS.  YEAH.
I MEAN THERE ARE TIMES WHEN
HEIDI AND I WERE SUPPOSED TO
DRESS UP AS DETERGENT BOTTLES
AND PRESENT A CHALLENGE.  IF WE
DO IT, DO IT IN LA AND WE'LL GO
ON "LET'S MAKE A DEAL" OR DO
IT ON HALLOWEEN.  WE COULDN'T
DO THE SHOWS WITHOUT THE
SPONSORS.
WE HAVE SUCH A SLIM BUDGET.
THERE WOULD BE NO SHOW.  WE DO
THE BEST WE CAN WITH IT.
SPEAKER:  GREAT.  A QUESTION
RIGHT HERE.
AUDIENCE MEMBER:  HI, TIM GUNN.
I HAVE TWO QUESTIONS.  I'M
SORRY.  I WANT TO KNOW WHO YOUR
FAVORITE LOOK WAS AT THE MET
GALA LAST NIGHT.  AND WHAT YOUR
FAVORITE BAR IN D.C.
IS?
SPEAKER:  LAST NIGHT.  WELL, I
MEAN,
HONORING IT'S REALLY A LICENSE
TO WEAR HALLOWEEN COSTUMES.  AND
A LOT OF PEOPLE DID.  I TENDED
-- I MEAN, PERSONALLY.  I'M AN
OLD DUDDY.
I LIKE THE LOOKS.  I THOUGHT
JENNIFER LOPEZ LOOKED FANTASTIC.
BUT WAS SHE OUT OF STEP WITH THE
THEME OF WHAT THE SHOW WAS?
YOU KNOW, I'M NOT PERMITTED TO
ATTEND THE GALA.  I'M VERY PROUD
OF THAT.  BECAUSE THE HOSTESS
AND I ARE ARCH ENEMIES.  [CHEERS
AND APPLAUSE].  OH, MY
GOODNESS.
DO YOU NOT KNOW THIS STORY?  IT
WAS AN OUTCOME OF TRUTH TELLING.
SPEAKER:  OH, MY GOSH.
SPEAKER:  DO YOU WANT TO HEAR
IT?
SPEAKER:  IT'S JUST YOU AND ME,
DEAR.  YES.
SPEAKER:  I WAS BEING
INTERVIEWED BY ROBERT YORK AT
THE NEW YORK POST FOR A COVER
STORY THEY WERE DOING
CORRESPONDING TO A PREMIERE OF
PROJECT RUNWAY, A NEW SEASON OF
PROJECT RUNWAY.  AND HE ASKED
ME, WHAT IS THE MOST
UNFORGETTABLE THING THAT YOU
HAVE EVER SEEN IN FASHION.  AND
HE SAID, I DON'T MEAN AN ARTICLE
OF CLOTHING.  BUT SOMETHING
THAT HAS HAPPENED.  AND I SAID
OH, THAT'S EASY.  I SAID I WAS
WATCHING ANNA WINTOR BEING
CARRIED DOWN FIVE FLIGHTS OF
STAIRS FROM HER FASHION SHOW.
JUST THE FACTS.  NO
EDITORIALIZING.  JUST THE FACTS.
CAME OUT ON SUNDAY OF COURSE.
AND IT WAS A LITTLE BOX.  AND I
WAS TEACHING THE FOLLOWING
MONDAY MORNING.  I GET BACK TO
MY OFFICE.  SO THIS IS PARSON'S
OF COURSE.  AND I WISH I CAN
RECREATE MY EXPRESSION AND
MOVEMENTS.  THERE WAS A WHILE
YOU WERE OUT LITTLE POST-IT
THING THAT WAS ALSO LIKE OLD
DINOSAURS.  ANNA WINTOR'S OFFICE
CALLED.  PLEASE RETURN.  WELL,
I
WAS -- I THINK EVERYTHING
OPENED.  SO I CALLED.  ACTUALLY
I DIDN'T CALL RIGHT AWAY.  I
THOUGHT, WHEN WILL SHE PROBABLY
BE AT LUNCH?  YEAH, SO
INTUITIVELY, I THOUGHT 1:30.  SO
I CALLED.  AND SHE WAS AT
LUNCH.
SO I THOUGHT OKAY.  DEED DONE.
HOWEVER, SOMEONE ELSE PICKED UP
THE PHONE AFTER BEING ON HOLD
FOR A FEW SECONDS.  NAMED
PATRICK MCCONNEL.  HE WAS THE
DIRECTOR OF COMMUNICATIONS FOR
VOGUE.  AND HE SAID MS. WINTOR
DEMANDS A RETRACTION.  OF WHAT,
I ASKED.  SHE DEMANDS THAT YOU
CALL THE POST AND HAVE THEM
PRINT A RETRACTION.  AND I SAID,
THAT WOULD IMPLY IT'S NOT TRUE.
I SAID IT IS TRUE.
AND THIS HAPPENED.  AND I KEEP
A DIARY.
IT WAS SEPTEMBER 12TH.  THE
METROPOLITAN FIDDLING.  I WAS ON
THE FLOOR.  AND THE
METROPOLITAN IS AN OLD
INDUSTRIAL BUILDING.
IT'S ONE BIG FREIGHT ELEVATOR.
AND MS. WINTOR WILL NOT RIDE IN
AN ELEVATOR AND ALONE WITH HER
SECURITY DETAIL.  SO WE WERE --
MY COLLEAGUES AND I WERE GOING
TO THE SHOW AND SPECULATING NOT
HOW SHE WOULD ARRIVE, THAT CAN
BE EASY FACILITATED.  GET HER IN
ALONE.  GET HER OUT.  BUT HOW
SHE WOULD DESCEND.  BECAUSE IT'S
A FRANTIC MAD RUSH.  YOU GOT TO
LEAVE THAT LOCATION.  AND GET
TO THE NEXT LOCATION FOR THE
NEXT SHOW.  SO WE WERE STANDING.
ALWAYS HAPPY TO STAND AT A
FASHION SHOW.  OR WE WERE
DIRECTLY OPPOSITE ANNA WINTOR
AND HAD TWO HUGE BODY GUARDS
INSIDE OF HER.  AND THOUGHT,
WHAT IS GOING TO HAPPEN WHEN THE
LIGHTS COME ON.  WELL, WE RAN
OUT BEHIND THEM.  AND THERE WAS
A BIG GIANT OPEN STAIRCASE.
AGAIN, A BIG INDUSTRIAL
BUILDING.  AND THE TWO SECURITY
PEOPLE MADE A FIRE MAN'S LOCK.
AND SHE SAT IN IT.  AND THEY
WOOSHED HER DOWN THE STAIRS.  SO
I RAN TO THE WINDOW, TO SEE
WHETHER THEY WOULD PUT HER DOWN
ON THE SIDEWALK OR TAKE HER TO
THE CAR.  THEY
TOOK HER TO THE CAR.  DOWN 18TH
STREET THEY WENT.  I DIDN'T SAY
ANY OF THAT.
HAD IT IN MY DIARY, ALL OF THE
INFORMATION THAT I GAVE WITH
PATRICK MCCONNEL.  OH, DEAR, OH,
DEAR, OH, DEAR.  SO GOOD DAY,
PATRICK.
[LAUGHTER].  TUESDAY HE CALLS.
HE CALLS.  AND HE SAID, YOU'RE
GOING TO LOVE THIS.
HE SAID, I'LL HAVE YOU KNOW MS.
WINTOR KNOWS HOW TO WORK A
MANOLO.  WHAT?  SHE COULD TAKE
THOSE STAIRS.  LOOK, I KNOW MS.
WINTOR KNOWS HOW TO WORK A
MANOLO.  IT WASN'T WHETHER SHE
CAN WALK DOWN THE STAIRS.  IT'S
ABOUT SPEED.  THESE GUYS AND
THEIR FLAT SECURITY SHOES WERE
BEING MUCH FASTER THAN SHE WOULD
HAVE EVER GONE IN THE MANOLOS.
ONCE AGAIN, OH, DEAR.  OH, DEAR.
SO THE FOLLOWING DAY, HE CALLS
AND HE SAYS ALL RIGHT.  WE HAVE
TO GET THE LAWYERS INVOLVED.
AND I SAID, GOOD.  BECAUSE THIS
MEANS WE CAN'T TALK ANYMORE.  SO
THEN, YOU'RE GOING TO LOVE THIS
PART EVEN MORE.  A COLLEAGUE OF
MINE WHO I HAD AN APPOINTMENT
WITH IN MY OFFICE, CAME AND
LOOKED AT ME AND SAID YOU LOOK
HORRIBLE.  WHAT'S GOING ON?  AND
SO I TOLD HIM THE STORY.  AND
HE SAID, I WAS THERE.  I SAW IT.
HE PICKED UP THE PHONE.  HE
CALLED PATRICK AND HE SAID IT'S
SO AND SO.  AND HERE IS THE PART
THAT YOU WON'T BELIEVE.  I
CAN'T SAY SO AND SO'S NAME
ANYMORE.
BECAUSE BY AN ATTORNEY, ANNA
WINTOR THREATENED HIS JOB
BECAUSE OF THIS ASSOCIATION WITH
ME.  BUT ANYWAY, HE SAVED ME.
SO HE SAID, I WAS THERE.  I SAW
IT.  AND OF COURSES THERE WERE
PROBABLY 100 PEOPLE WHO -- WELL
PROBABLY NOT.  THERE WERE
PROBABLY 50 OF US GATHERED
AROUND THE STAIRWELL.  BUT SHE
INSTILLED SUCH FEAR IN PEOPLE
THAT NO ONE WOULD SAY ANYTHING.
WELL YES, SHE DOES SCARE ME.  SO
I DECIDED TO TAKE THE HIGH
ROAD.
I CALLED THE FLOREST THAT I
USED.  AND I SAID I WANT AN
ENORMOUSLY STAGGERING BEAUTIFUL
ALL WHITE ARRANGEMENT SENT TO
MS. WINTOR.  AND I WROTE MY OWN
NOTE.  TOOK IT TO THE FLORIST TO
ACCOMPANY THIS.  AND THOUGHT,
OKAY.  THIS IS THE RIGHT THING
TO DO.  HOWEVER, I HAD A SECRET
EMBEDDED MESSAGE IN THE WHITE
FLOWERS.  HERE IN WESTERN
CULTURE IT MEANS PEACE.  BUT IN
ASIAN CULTURES
IT MEANS DEATH.
[LAUGHTER].
GOT IT.  HOW DID WE GET OFF ON
THIS TANGENT?  ANYWAY --
SPEAKER:  I DON'T THINK WE WILL
TOP THAT.
SPEAKER:  OH, THE GALA.  I WAS
INVITED.  WHEN LIZ
CLAIREBORNE, MY BOSS OR CEO
INVITED ME.  THE FIRST YEAR,
YOU'RE COMING WITH ME.  DON'T BE
RIDICULOUS.  I BUY A TABLE
EVERY YEAR.  AND COME WITH ME.
WITH HIS TAIL BETWEEN HIS LEGS
HE CAME TO ME AND SAID SORRY YOU
HAVE BEEN UNINVITED.  AND SHE
GOES THROUGH THAT LIST.  AND I
DON'T WANT TO GO TO THAT THING
ANYWAY.  WHAT WAS YOUR SECOND
QUESTION?
SPEAKER:  WE HAVE ONE LAST
QUESTION.
AUDIENCE MEMBER:  HI, WOW,
THAT'S LOUD.  WHAT WAS YOUR
FAVORITE CHALLENGE ON PROJECT
RUNWAY?
SPEAKER:  I HAVE TO SAY IT'S
VERY SENTIMENTAL FOR ME.  SEASON
1 CHALLENGE 1 WHEN WE HAD TO GO
TO THE HIGH END FABRIC STORE
AND WE TOOK THEM TO A GROCERY
STORE.
AND WE SAID OKAY.  HERE IS YOUR
MONEY.  SHOP FOR ALL OF THESE
UNCONVENTIONAL MATERIALS.  IT
DOESN'T APPEAR IN THE SHOW.  BUT
ONE OF MY FAVORITE MOMENTS WITH
AUSTIN SCARLET WHO WON THAT
CHALLENGE WITH THE INCREDIBLE
CORN HUSK DRESS.  IT WAS
STAGGERING.  HE HAD A SHOPPING
CART FILLED WITH CORN.  AND ON
TOP OF IT WERE ALL OF THESE BAGS
OF POTATO CHIPS.  I SAID, I
UNDERSTAND THE CORN.  BUT WHAT
ARE THE POTATO CHIPS FOR?  AND
HE SAID FOR THE BUS RIDE HOME.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
ARE FABULOUS.
SPEAKER:  THANK YOU.  [CHEERS
AND APPLAUSE].
AUDIENCE.
THANK YOU.  THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].